a view over the rooftops of Barcelona
parque guell is situated on a hill not
far from the city center it's the
creation of the famously eccentric
architect Antoni gaudí originally
planned as a private preserve for 60
families of Catalonia's elite today it's
a public park and it's just as popular
with Barcelona residents as with
tourists drawing about 8 million
visitors each year
Juwan Roca head at the city's Historical
Museum is an expert on the parks history
it's real exceptional because when gaudi
made this residential area for way he
tried to find the best of nature and the
best of architectural form in the whole
western tradition to make a place which
had a kind of transcendence even a kind
of heaven the guard houses at the
entrance sport flora and fauna motifs
typical of the local incarnation of our
novel called modern yzma catherine the
park was later between 1900 and 1914 it
features a unique harmony of nature and
architecture gaudi plans it all down to
the tiniest detail like the viaducts
integrated into the landscape were there
built in bird's nests
gadi had originally planned a meeting
area for residents between the
colonnades here he had to find the right
scale and to find the right proportion
not only to saying the square which is
about but also to create a written which
goes from classic to anti classic from
culture to nature and if you walk around
you will find the different perspectives
which are not the same all the time so
it's a very dynamic conception of
structure which is rather static Antony
Cody was one of the pioneering
architects of the 20th century in 1900
industrialist ocelli Quayle hired him to
build a residential area overlooking the
city the project failed
and so in 1926 Parc güell was open to
the public
only two of the residential buildings
were actually constructed no buyer was
found so Guardi himself moved into the
model building that was designed by one
of his assistants but he lived in it for
almost 20 years today it houses a museum
devoted to Gerdes life and work among
its exhibits are items of furniture
designed by the architect
the park offers a view towards the
Cathedral of Sagrada família guddi's
most famous work which is still not
completed but the very best view of the
city is from the parks Esplanade
it was originally planned as an open-air
theatre but today from its vantage point
it's the city that's the show the
serpentine-like bench features a special
mosaic technique that Cody favoured
Gaudi decided to use the Train Cadiz
franca this means broken pieces broken
pieces from reused materials to mix the
different elements in a very free way so
that form puts you in the front of the
city and on the other part you can sit
and participate the social life in the
square
local residents have free admission to
the part of the park that's protected as
a national monument to raise funds to
maintain the park an eight hero entrance
fee for tourists was introduced last
year I like the way the stone terraces
and sculptures have been woven into the
landscape they follow the contours of
the land the park is really beautiful
Barcelona's incredible quiet descends an
evening the park güell is not just an
architectural Monument it's a lovely
place to take a break from the city's
hustle and bustle